The next question. I am Rashan from Sri
Lanka. I am a Hindu by birth. But I
never believed in Hinduism or another
religion from my school time till now.
But I trust, believe and follow Islam.
Same time I never convert as a Muslim
because of my parent. So I would like to
know what should I do about it. I am
working at health and life insurance
company in Sri Lanka. Our company
invests the premiums for government
treasury bronze and doing more business
like electronic devices, hospitals,
foods. I'm working at health and life
insurance company in Sri Lanka. A
company invests the premiums for
government treasury bonds and doing more
business like electronic devices,
hospital foods, cities, exports and
imports etc. I sell more policies with
without any kind of extra money. They
only get what they saved for entire term
at maturity. In them hospitalization
they can settle the hospital bill by
using a policy. in death or disability
they can claim some extra bonus if
someone thinks it's interest what can I
do for it the question posed by rashan
from Sri Lanka that he's Hindu by birth
but never believed in Hinduism full life
and he believed in Islam same time never
converted as a Muslim because of parent
so like to know what should I do as far
if you believe in Islam and you believe
in the teachings
of Allah subhanana wa tala and the last
and final message my first request to
you would be that see to you you accept
Islam as long as you believe there's one
God and you believe there's no one else
that deserve worship and you believe
that prophet Muhammad is a messenger of
God then my request to you would be that
immediately as soon as possible accept
Islam because we do not know how long
we'll live I'm not sure whether I'll
live tomorrow whether I'll see tomorrow
or not so if you as you said If you
studied Hinduism and you agree with it
and you want to accept Islam, my request
to you would be see to it that you don't
delay. Don't wait for the right occasion
along with some birthday of someone else
or don't don't wait that you know you'll
do it later on. My advice to you would
be that see to it that you accept Islam
as soon as possible. Coming to a second
question that you involved in in some of
the transaction which involves a da
there's insurance there are two types of
insurance one is the general insurance
which is there and the other is the
Islamic insurance called as takaful so
if you involve and get if you put
something in takaful or Islamic
insurance which takes care of you but if
you go to the conventional insurance it
deals with ribba and they will have a
different line and that's not acceptable
in Islam because ribba is a maj but so
what you have to do is that if we're
dealing with conventional insurance
which deals with ribba you should leave
it and see to that don't do it again but
if it is somewhat like the thing that it
is based on Islamic Sharia if it's takul
then there's no problem and it's
permitted Hope that answers the
question.